here for a special announcement is a
very special person miss Angie Dickinson
the late Jean Hersholt was an actor
second a good citizen first in his honor
the Academy has voted from time to time
the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award to
those members of our community who have
given selflessly of themselves in behalf
of others this year our Board of
Governors calls attention to a modest
gentleman who quietly but effectively
addresses himself to manifold tasks
attendant to the welfare of his fellow
man working behind the scenes without
fuss or fanfare Edmund L de petty vice
president of Warner Brothers has been
known to only a few of us yet his labor
his counsel and his unrelenting service
has benefited all of us through the
motion picture Relief Fund permanent
charities pension plans and health and
welfare funds none of which he needs
himself say for his own need to be of
service to others I'm honored to present
her shoulder ward and to add the
personal offense of everyone from our
back lot to our executive suites this
world could use more citizens like our
friend mr. Edna patty
this is unquestionably the proudest
moment of my 42 year career in our
industry and especially so since Jean
Hersholt and I worked as very close
friends for many years I thank the Board
of Governors of the Academy very
sincerely for voting me this
distinguished honor on a special deep
heartfelt thanks to Jack Warner for his
sympathetic understanding consideration
and interest in my many industry
activities during the 40 years of my
close association with him and a very
warm personal friendship and finally I
want to thank the thousands and
thousands of workers in this industry
who may have helped me merit this award
if indeed I do
Meredith at all thank you very much